so so we're um
so so i'd i'd like to
ask any questions from the floor um of
um and you can ask any question you like
of what you've heard this morning or
something that's occurred to you so
please um
and um yeah council north
so so there's a microphone on its way so
keeley is making her way to you
thank you
aggressively i suppose it's about money
clearly
village holes and things are used
relatively infrequently at least many in
my ward are
used a few hours a week and most and
clearly ground source heat
or as we'll see you're driving for 24 7.
so i really wondered whether there is
any financial
data available that can be used to
reassure or persuade whatever it is
other
authorities to take that route
um i have to add you know that i know at
the moment from sitting on planning
committees that persuading builders to
put
heat pumps in instead of gas boilers is
i don't know impossible but it's
certainly pretty darn difficult
certainly for communities the issue must
be
how does the finance pan out because
once you've made this sort of change
you're rather lost you can't turn things
off so any information there or
a good pointer to a source would be
great
yeah so so john would you like to stop
yeah so obviously the fund i mentioned
covers the feasibility and development
when it comes to actually buying the kit
and operating it then yeah
there are different parts of money that
can help with that um i know locally
there's the green suffolk funds that the
county council operate that might be
able to contribute some funding national
lottery is always a good source as well
as some of the landfill charities
depending on your location
um
i would say like we heard about ground
salty pumps there and there is a variety
of electric heating that can be suitable
for village halls i know everybody's
probably familiar with the old infrared
heaters
um there are like
if you've got a very well used hall
that's booked out all the time
ground sauce heat pump as we heard from
peter's probably going to be worthwhile
if it's only used a few hours a day or
every other day then you want a heating
system that's far more responsive
so at the other end electric radiant
heaters could be effective and still
eco-friendly as electricity decarbonizes
in the middle grounds
i've surveyed quite a few community
buildings and actually air conditioning
systems
are air source heat pumps that can do
both heating and cooling
you don't have to put radiators in or
under floor they just have wall
cassettes that blow warm air into the
room and they can actually be pretty
responsive in terms of heating up the
building pretty rapidly
and they're three to four times more
efficient than storage heaters or
electric radiators so again very
efficient use of electricity cheaper to
install because you don't have to do
bore holes
and then if you can yeah tie it up with
some local renewable electricity or
solar panels then all the better
and and sarah did you hear the question
about financial um ability to pay
i did yeah so um part of my role
as community energy advisor is also to
help communities find um grants suitable
so i can
always help community groups with that
aspect as john mentioned there's the
green subject fund uh national lottery
are always a good option as well um but
there are some other parts available and
so i can help with that side of things
as well
nothing in particular to add i think i'm
afraid on this one okay yeah as i said
we we are unusual in that we're so big
um and so many of my cancers are are
nuts
uh and therefore they'll do anything i
say which is very very useful but there
are people who are much smaller and the
one that i know about is rattlesnake so
rattlesn is running ground source heat
pump uh and heat exchanger and a couple
of other things
and therefore if you if anybody wants
figures for us a much smaller enterprise
uh tiny little village rattlesome if you
there are two more they escape me but
certainly rattlesnake is worth talking
to very they're a nice lot they'll share
anything with you
and and that's rattlestone pavilion um
village hall and um and they've had um a
ground source heat pump and solar in for
the last 10 years and so as peter says
that they've got some great figures in
fact it doesn't cost them anything to
run on that facility at all they put
they they get paid by the grid to run
that system at the moment so so that's a
great example if you want to go and
visit um
so
um
another question please um
glenn
thanks chris um
what do we do about um rented sector
poorly insulated listed properties
where you've got and financially
compromised tenants
how do we actually get
those properties
up to grade
what projects do we use
so the questions are on listed
properties specifically um so so
i don't have a lot of specific
information i'm afraid i know that it's
it's it's happening community energy
sector even there was a there was a
webinar this week that was talking about
conservation area in southeast london
that would that's doing this exact exact
question and i don't have the knowledge
of it because this is one of the things
we do i do is sit in the middle and see
what others are are doing and hear about
it but i'm not i'm not an expert in this
context myself but um i think that what
i would say is that uh
the community energy sector is engaging
with this um but
i yeah
we're kind of at the beginning of it
which i guess you are as well so um
others may be able to help me
and and maybe carports and thinking
about renewables not attached to the
building um and and that's i think is a
is a
perhaps a conversation with the
conservation officer about you know what
what's in the cartilage of a listed
building and how how much you can do
close to it i don't know
john
yeah
in my experience it seems to be quite a
high overlap between people that live in
listed buildings and want to act on
climate change it's um unfortunate but
um
yeah
you can do things with listed buildings
certainly you might have to apply for
planning permission but um organizations
like english heritage and the national
trust have done a lot with their own
estate and properties they've got some
really good examples to look at
um one project i've worked on down in
east sussex is the village of foal um
near um grindborn that sort of place and
it's yeah a very historic community it's
the bloomsbury group it's um you know
very
has that sort of old english vibe about
it and they've been looking at a
community-wide heap heat pump system
where
um
instead of the kind of centralized
large-scale energy center they're doing
what they call a shared loop ground
source heat pump it might work quite
well for the elsewhere and housing as
well where the bore hole is put in the
streets and then each house gets their
own mini heat pump which then connects
to that shared ground loop so it's a
very discreet system you don't have air
conditioning boxes you don't change the
appearance of the house from the outside
or the street scene but you help these
tenants connect to a renewable heating
system
it helps if there's the same landlord
because you're crossing properties but
there will be sticks coming in
legislatively where
um properties that are rented out have
to meet in minimum energy performance
standards so there will be that
incentive coming through
as well yeah and sarah do you have any
experience of listed buildings
um
massively to be honest i would sort of
echo what exactly what john has just
said really and there are organizations
out there um like heritage england that
have got case studies on their website
um of practical things that listed
buildings can do
um
but yeah
and and peter was the wesley hall um
listed no it wasn't listed midsummer
have some strange attitudes on listening
i hope there's none of them here
um
nothing victorian but uh we've shared
the same problems as the john peel
center in stone market where they had to
in fact they were told in the early
stage they would have to install some
ancillary heating
and i think they didn't and they
they had to retrofit it
you just have to realize that what we're
trying to do
is not doable 100
in all circumstances and our cases is a
good example because we are right next
door to each other one where we have to
stick in radiators as well because we
just couldn't possibly make it thermally
efficient enough a one purpose built
thermally efficient no problem at all so
there's a price to be paid for living in
the holistic building yeah yeah
so okay
this uh price to be paid for living in
enlisted building has got to be dealt
with by the district councils as far as
i'm concerned they are behind this the
curve by probably 10 or 15 years and
that listed buildings
are not well insulated difficult to
insulate and they need to be opening
their eyes to the climate emergency more
so than any other part of the planning
system let alone building new housing
estates that don't have community energy
systems so when can listed properties be
altered to have solar gain to have
a discrete solar pv on their roof and it
should be easy and not objected to by
planning control
[Music]
so
so thanks again that glenn and perhaps
that's something we can take back from
um from this event and and the facts
start that debate um with the um yeah
and internally so so thank you for that
just just one example if i may and it
isn't the whole aspect to it but um
community energy project has put solar
panels on the roof of salisbury
cathedral so in terms of listed
buildings you don't get much more listed
than that so
it just as an example of um
you may of a being able to learn from
others who have because they must have
had to overcome the challenges of trying
to persuade those who who weren't up for
it kind of thing so and there's
certainly some people have managed that
persuasion in certain places
great and so then the next question
okay i'm involved in the early stages of
a modernization program
for a 1950s village hall
that is quite
heavily used
at one stage
65 percent of our available slots will
be used in a week
one of the things
i'm considering is trying to find
sponsorship
now if you've got any particular tips
please give them just to me not to
everyone here
but
would you think i'm wasting my time or
is it worth trying to find sponsorships
we've got no large employer
in the parish
of two and a half thousand people
your advice would be very helpful on the
question of sponsorship
thank you
it's a novel
idea and not something that i have heard
of community energy trying to tie in
sponsorship with
other forms of investment but i don't
know whether you've con
what's more normal in the community
energy sector is community shares um so
i don't know if you're familiar with
that but that's where um you form a
small co-operative in the village and
they issue shares which people you can
have a different different ways of
structuring the investment
in terms of you can change the price or
the minimum
investment for local people to bring the
to make sure there's a local element to
it
but that's the one of the most common
ways of raising funds for projects i
think it's more common for electricity
generation than it is for heat um
or retrofit
so i don't quite i don't have a model
that comes to mind where they've done
exactly the same kind of thing that you
were talking about but it it really is
very interesting when we see that the
volumes of money which are raised by
community energy organizations to to
fund this kind of energy project because
it just
comes out of nowhere in the sense that
it's it's investment which probably
wouldn't be tapped into otherwise but
people seem to have a very significant
appetite for
investing their spare money and
obviously this does depend on the
socio-demographic profile of where
you're from but
there's a significant appetite to invest
money in
projects which i a have this real local
element and local roots local benefit
but also the environmental element to it
and
either changing the way electricity is
consumed or how buildings function so um
yeah i can talk to you about that and
how it works and point you in the
direction of that um the other thing is
kind of is crowdfunding which is a bit
similar
but it's a bit more kind of public and
doesn't function in quite the same way
as an investment
but those are the more common ways in
the community energy sector and i think
as i say it always surprises me how much
money people in there are willing to
invest in their communities
so
that may be options for you
and and peter and when you put your
funding together some of that was with
using the the precepts from the parish
council
yeah i mean
the big winner is the pwlv the public
works loan board if you can work with
your parish council and get that money
it is incredibly doable it's incredibly
cheap and the beauty of it is the people
who will be paying for that money are
the people who in
in future years will be enjoying the
benefits so it's not like taking from
your reserves the money that people have
given you for the last 10 years you're
taking money from people in the future
because they'll be paying the loan back
but what we have also done to refurbish
this pub is to set up what humanity is
here a community enterprise
which is set up through the financial
services authority etc etc and you have
to do this thing um filling forms and
you have to fill all these forms in lots
of forms
you fill in and then you can you then
establish a shared prospectus
uh it's it's what community purpose and
community shops do community heating
does it as well for example the most
famous example locally is the locks of
gilderson they did exactly this and from
the community of gelderston
which is only 100 people or something in
their village but they've got a very
very wide
catchment of users of their existing pub
to refurb that pub they went to share
issue and got 600 000 pounds
now we're going to a share issue and
we'll get something like a hundred
thousand but probably made quite a big
dent in the heat pump for a village hall
and to go back to your original premise
the figures you're saying are ex you're
going exactly the right way if you've
got 60 occupancy there's no doubt about
it if you possibly can go to that room
and john
um yeah i supposed to
add something different to what's been
said already um like yesterday was the
business day there may well be
connections to be made through
that network like i know businesses like
sponsor tree planting to
add to their kind of carbon balance
sheet maybe there's an angle there and
perhaps on the crowd funding side as
well um yeah we've heard communities be
successful with it and actually local
authorities like babur and mid-suffolk
um are do increasingly have the option
to do their own local climate bond um
it's something that's been trialled by
several local councils now instead of
borrowing from the public works loan
boards they can actually issue one
directly um to raise investment from
their citizens to then have a pool
to invest in green projects in their
localities so
yeah on the enterprising side there is
that kind of crowd source finance but
yeah it's certainly possible to get
donations and sponsorship as well i
would say
and
donations are always the easiest
form of funding to collect because it's
normally a one-to-one conversation um
without necessarily um
you know having to sort forms in that
peter alluded to so and the fun of that
and it's sort of the
um and you you said in your question how
you there's a large employer in the in
in the village maybe just that you know
a personal personal approach to that
employee employer to see if they would
sponsor your project um you know that's
a nice first step
but um sarah can i ask you about sort of
the you know the various ways funding
packages get put together at groundworks
and and whether sponsorship and
donations are part of that
yeah so i don't have any experience with
any sort of sponsorship um sort of
agreements but
i mean my typical
involvement is helping secure grant
funding
groundwork ourselves we don't um have
any grants to offer unfortunately um but
i can you know point you in the
direction of some funds um i think it
can be done definitely there are
examples of villagers who have um
funded heat pumps solely through grant
funding um it just requires perseverance
um as you know as as other people
mentioned there's a lot of films to fill
out um
and just be prepared that you're not
going to get all the grants you apply
for but there are there is funding
available
um so yeah
great thank you
um and
um another question
you can just probably sort of um you're
thinking about your lunch and so i'm
keeping your hands down purposely so um
the
so so so it's it's i'm just um
so
there's one um there's one can i say
something yeah yeah i thought you'd like
that
one of the key things
from our perspective is the way your
community
whether it's
the parish council or the village hall
committee or whoever it is it is the way
that is structured
because unless if if you have got
arguing factions within your community
so the village hall committee won't talk
to the parish council who won't talk to
the community whatever it is and the wi
gets in the middle of all of it
if you've got all of that you're you're
starting off from a very very difficult
standpoint one of the big benefits that
we've had
is that
by devious means
which i'm not allowed to mention really
we've actually got everybody
pulling together
so you've got
you know the old argument the same six
people do everything of course it is but
that can actually be quite handy if what
they're doing
is being on the parish council and
borrowing money to give to the whole
committee to do the hall and to give to
the pub committee and to the the
affordable housing group so you've got a
finger in all of those pies and you only
need five to make a hand and you've got
a handout i just thought that's quite a
good one
write it down by all means i'm here all
week um
so i think that is very important the
two important things amongst the
important things are know how much you
need rather than
laughing about saying we'd like to do
this village whole thing and it'll be
quite a lot of money it doesn't take a
lot particularly if you've got people in
your community with a few skills it
doesn't take a lot to
wet an informed finger and say it's
going to be
a hundred grand or 200 or 300 or
whatever whatever it is and we
registered our pub thing we've wet the
finger and we're coming out at just over
the million to do the pub up
that gives you a very important
place from which to either run and hide
or start a discussion
because if it is only 60 grand donations
are great
but if it's a hundred thousand or 150 or
whatever donations are you know they're
they're whistling in the wind really
you've got to go for big stuff and
what we don't do
is engage in what we call
coffee morning politics where everybody
works their little socks off and we made
84 pounds
towards a hundred thousand pounds worth
of heat from by the time you put it in
the diary
inflation has knocked it into touch
anyway
so know the scale of your thing and try
and bring your people together i people
ring me up for obscure reasons i think
it's because it's free
and ask for and that's the very first
thing i will say to them is if you've
got a war in your village forget it
get that sorted out first so that you've
got everybody kicking to the same goal
and and off you go and i mentioned in in
my presentation a couple of wars and
they were quite serious political stuff
we were the village from hell for a long
time it was great
um we we had part of our presence with
body armor it was that was useful um
but we've gradually the other thing is
of course is hang in there and where the
bug is down
and that's that's the other way forward
so that's three good things
sorry
chris i thought you were floundering to
fill in time there it's a very
insightful um
we're getting there we're getting a lot
of understanding about how it works in
elsewhere so that's that's great thank
you um and
so so glenn you got another question
so this is an important point um can you
just repeat that into the microphone
because not everybody will have heard
that okay so
within my question earlier i mentioned
financially compromised in the rented
sector we need to get those people
engaged as well they cannot be left out
in our journey to net zero
okay and i noticed the green party in
their autumn conference i'm promoting
today that 320 pounds should go to every
household in in the country to help with
the winter heating and so there's the
green party sort of making a statement
and challenging the um present
government and so
are things like that our physical um
payments and so forth a good idea um and
and so sarah what what do you think
yeah so i definitely think um
schemes and incentives are like that are
a good idea um i also think it comes
down to
the information that we're sharing with
people and so for a lot of you know the
financially disadvantaged people
we're promoting expensive options to
them but the journey to net zero doesn't
have to be expensive um you know i think
a lot of people forget about behavioural
change and that can actually have a
massive impact on getting two net zero
and that that can be as simple as just
turning lights off when you leave a room
and those are so simple
everyone can do them whether they rent
whether they own regardless of how much
money they have you know it's it's
simple things like that that can have
quite a big difference um on
on you know the journey to net zero so i
think it's also about engaging people
with that side of things as well
john
yeah it's a certainly a very important
point and there is
potentially a lot of support out there
for people in vulnerable situations
whether it's like help paying their fuel
bills as a warm homes healthy people
project run locally and suffolk their
support from the energy companies and
networks the difficulty is knowing where
these people are and that's where the
people in this room the communities can
really help because you know
um through the coffee mornings through
village events you know the people in
your community that might need that help
um so having some local forum or local
energy champion that can look out for
your neighbors and steer them to the
support that's needed that is a big
opportunity there um i would also add
there is a distinction to be made
with climate action carbon reduction and
fuel property action because there is
actually quite a correlation between
wealth and carbon footprint the more
money you have the more you spend on
cars and travel and heating
and so there's a little bit of
distinction to be made it will be the
more affluent people in the communities
that buy the electric cars first that
can afford to put heat pumps in that
doesn't mean that the people at the
other end of the spectrum can't involved
and there is an action for them to do as
well
um i think
yeah with climate change we've got very
good at telling people the scary story
about how bad things can be if we don't
act and now's the time to start telling
that story of how good things can be if
we do
and philly yeah so i i i can't answer
these this i guess nobody can answer the
specific question how do you get
landlords to to to retrofit and invest
um that's a one that we're gonna have to
solve as a nation but um
one thing that the community energy
sector does in addition to what's
already been mentioned um is
the giving people a stake in the energy
system and
there are a few ways of this one of
which is exactly has been has been said
is being local and being the people who
give the advice
that makes a big difference in terms of
the trust
if you're if a vulnerable person a poor
person or an older person whatever your
aspect of vulnerability or multiple are
somebody who lives in your community
coming to try and help you understand
how the how to save energy or how to
engage with energy is very different to
somebody coming from npower um
that's that's very well known in the
sector that local people are much more
trusted and so that's why local
organizations that do this that bring
local people together um that that
changes the relationship with with
vulnerable people
and there are ways to get training in
that so you can there's training in how
to be an energy advisor so there are
lots of community organizations london
has a load of them
where they train up and energy advisors
and they they're able to provide
services that target this kind of group
of people and help them
understand even things as basic as the
fact that you can change your energy
supplier and that's that's the very
first step some people don't even know
that that's possible so you've got to
start really at that very low level with
how you provide information but as i
said it's who is providing information
which is also important the other thing
that i would say is
the the way that any kind of community
local community action of this nature
brings in everybody no matter their
ability to invest so as john said it
will be the more affluent people who are
both able to take their own action but
they're the ones who've got a thousand
pounds sitting around that they can
invest in your community share offer
but that potentially could lead to a
situation where the more vulnerable in
your community are not participating in
the project
so i've seen certain things in the past
where they've dropped the share issue
minimum uh buy-in to 250 pounds well
there are millions of people in this
country who do not have anywhere near
250 pounds sitting around that they can
invest so there are other organizations
there's some in london where it's one
pound and that gives you
ownership you're a part owner of that
community energy organization so you
have one vote just like everybody else
no matter whether they've invested 10
grand in it
and that again gives that connection to
place and so when those people are
involved in the decision making process
whatever it is and however down the line
we get to engage landlords or whether
it's a community heat system or whatever
it is if you if you've
set up your organization and it has made
deliberate efforts to bring everybody in
to the decision-making process then i
think you'll find that that process goes
very differently and has a very
different experience of inclusion
that's
i think that's an important point well
made about minimum minimum entry levels
isn't it and people having yes our the
community i mentioned our community land
trust which is going to build the houses
at the back of the pub and that we uh is
already set up and the minimum buy for
that will be one pound simply so that
nobody is excluded and the aim there is
we we do feel this um
this dissonance between ourselves
as the the very important people that
matter to make the decisions and the
ordinary people
we're very aware of that and the clt as
well as the pub scheme as well is an
attempt at our level because we find
that a district level and certainly a
county level we're we're on a lower
planet they don't really want to know
about us
so the clt very specifically in this
instance is going to deal with that and
the heating is a very important because
as i've read the papers recently it's
getting more expensive i think
yeah i thought it was right there um so
it is an increasingly uh important thing
and if we can bring them in through
their one pound share so that they have
one vote same as everybody else uh we
shall do that and it's we take it to be
very important
great thank you very much
if you don't mind we'd like to finish
the the panel um session session here
because um
lunch is um ready and so um i'd like to
thank um the panelists for for coming up
here and and um telling us all about it
and and sarah from your virtual place um
so thank you for coming and and thank
you for groundworks for providing lots
of lots of funding opportunities for
um businesses and organizations to be
able to make make that step forward into
making something happen so thank you for
that
thank you thank you
[Applause]
you